how did you get from what you were doing
with with music and YouTube videos and
Netflix to your first film how'd you
make that leap um I don't know I was you
know I had the script written for a few
years and I tried to get it made and
tried to get the money for it and kind
of couldn't and then made my last
special and felt like I had sort of
enough momentum at the time to get some
undisclosed amount of money to make this
film and I was lucky enough to do it but
yeah I mean it was a lot of yeah you
know I've been I've just been trying to
work at it first sort of ten years I
started started when I was 17 or so and
I've just been a yeah I'm very happy
I've had things almost happen and then
fall apart or ever I'm very very happy
this is the first thing though I feel
like there's two feelings that permeate
this film it's like anxiety and optimism
it's like an anxiety sandwich with
optimism at the front and at the at the
end with your wonderful like inner
monologues and the bread gets stuck in
your braces just like exactly do you
feel like this is your outlook on life
you know is is like does do does this
story reflect how you look at life is it
an anxiety sandwich is it like optimism
bookending you know this well if I could
continue with this metaphor the
toothpick would be no um the crust of
sort of creation with a sort of rye
bread of wit no yeah I mean I I wanted
to write about my own anxiety that that
was sort of the impulse for the script
it wasn't middle-schoolers it was like I
wanted to write about how I was feeling
at the time which was nervous you know I
was just feeling really nervous and
unsure and I wanted to write about what
it felt like to be alive right now which
to me felt confusing and strange like
everything was changing and I was trying
to grasp at things they were slipping
through my hands and what is happening
and I feel really hot right now I need a
drink of water and that just reminded me
of middle school you know really truly
but yeah there's some yeah there's
optimism I think hopefully through it
but it's her optimism that's why it's
meaningful to me you know it's it's her
hope it's hope constructed out of
you know what culture on fire or
whatever she has to be dealing with you
know so um yeah sure I definitely like
get the anxious thing oh you else what
do you think you'll see he had a great
answer so mine is I feel nervous to go
we're hopeful that we won't be those
soon right we'll see why tell the story
through the eyes of a 13 year old girl I
I don't want to assume too much but I
don't think you've ever been one yeah
beautiful choice I was one back when the
earth was cooling I also I also
graduated from eighth grade and that's
one of the things I like is that this
isn't just you know that this isn't a
memoir this isn't like you don't watch
it and think oh yeah I remember I mean
the emotions are there the technology
has changed but I just like that it's
you're you're a metaphor for maybe what
we felt in eighth grade and kind of what
we're feeling now I mean I felt like a
lot of that resonated now though these
many years after I passed through eighth
grade so yeah yeah and I feel that way
too you know it's like why can't you
know an epic story about the human
condition be about a girl wandering into
a pool party and not you know some in a
one-piece yeah exactly and also
hopefully it serves the specific
circumstance that she's going through as
well but the initial impulse for the
script was watching hundreds of videos
of kids online expressing themselves you
know and I just found them really really
fascinating the boys tended to talk
about fortnight and the girls tended to
talk about their souls so it was like
okay probably gonna write about a girl
not being cruel to the boys but the
girls are just slightly deeper at that
age and then also I I really wanted to
make a movie about this age that wasn't
nostalgic and I like nostalgic films I
like films that feel like a memory and
hopefully this you know film can make
you feel nostalgic but it wasn't where
we were operating from you know my
disconnect from her is twofold I was
never a 13 year old girl I was also
never 13 now you know and both of those
things lend themselves to a very
specific experience so it being a girl I
just kind of had to subjugate myself to
the truth of what she was going through
and go like I don't I don't know what
she's been through
instead the film is gonna walk her life
with her as she does for the first time
and not go you know these are all
memories and these are all things we've
processed you know something like a
brand party when you remember it we know
it's a cultural standard so we sort of
normalize it in our heads but when you
see it as she does fresh it's like what
is it like this a bunch of kids whose
bodies are exploding half-dressed around
a hole in the ground with water like how
is this legal like it's just like so
like part of it was wanting to do that
like because that's truly how I feel
about my anxiety I would love to be 10
years away from my anxiety looking back
nostalgically on it but that's not the
experience of anxiety you know it's
visceral and current so yeah it being a
girl I just had to I was I felt like I
was going through first grade eighth
grade for the first time again first
grade for the eighth time again however
the math adds up see what do you think
about that people ask me if I'm
surprised that Bo wrote such a
compelling story about a girl and I'm
really not because I truly see it as
like not I don't know him researching
eighth-grade girls and there you go
eighth grade girl story but it's about
us right now and you know how everything
feels explodey
I don't know but I mean yeah basically
what he said I feel like a nervous
person writing about a nervous person as
much as I feel like no truly as a man
writing about a girl um and also I have
most vividly connected to films
personally that I don't demographically
align with that's the miracle of movies
to me when I can see myself vividly
personally in someone that is on the
surface not the same as me I mean I you
know well that's a great character when
you watch it and you think you know no I
am NOT a black person in the south and
the 20s but I can relate to what they're
going through and and that's the
brilliance of this so well done you okay
so you came up with this incredible
story and now you had to have the
perfect actress the perfect person to
tell that story so give us a little and
we couldn't find that sir settled for it
our ban sirs I really I hey we saw
hundreds of kids here I mean like
hundreds of kids and like it was like
the lights were off before she came on
like truly like he was dead it was it
was it was meaningless before she read
it because every other kid that would
read it would play it like it felt like
a confident kid pretending to be shy and
when she played it it felt like a shy
kid pretending to be confident which is
actually what that is everyone else
played shy which is like played shy is
this inactive cowering thing and she
knows and she played shyness as active
shyness is wanting to speak at every
moment and not being able to when I
watch it I don't see Elsie playing Kayla
I see Kayla playing all the people she
wants to be in every moment which is
impressive for an actor of any age I
think and it is it really truly I really
believe that and like she'll be super
humble about it and act late but like it
is written - the monologues are written
like yeah um so the thing about being
yourself is like I'm reading this off a
piece of paper you know people don't
give her credit cuz they think it's do
you think I made like homeward bound or
babe there's a dog movie or it's like at
the enemy I was just like Ubu and I'll
figure a movie around it's not that I
can show you 9 takes where she stumbles
in the same place every time yeah you
know it's it's I think it's incredibly
difficult to be able to realistically
and reliably portray something that is
very close to you I think it's very easy
to became and a top hat and be like yeah
whatever you mean like much harder to
put you know be something that has cut
so close to the bone she graduated
eighth grade a week later we were
filming and a week after we stopped
filming she went to her freshman year of
high school and she didn't get into her
school play
so I promised her I'd say this on this
wonderful stage mr. Dona from Thousand
Oaks High School is a piece of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's like Jordan not making his high
school team so that brings me to the
script I understand that you is it true
that he didn't let you read the whole
script except maybe one time I read the
full script one time and that was right
after I got the role okay was that
liberating or terrifying okay no I mean
honestly cuz I was like I was having
actual anxiety attacks before this isn't
like oh man she's method I mean I was
gonna say I think I'm seeing the madness
here yeah yeah I don't know it was it
was it was also very liberating though
as you said because I mean I got the
lines for each day on the day of and I'm
pretty minimal time to memorize yeah
thankfully it worked out but no I mean I
got to have them kind of in the back of
my head and that let me be more natural
and he wrote a lot of poems and pauses
yeah
can one of you tell me what the hell
Gucci means well Gucci was my creation
[Laughter]
no I love it
funny cuz it's like you mean what does
it mean the truth is I don't know what
it means either no I mean if we're being
honest like you know I was on the East
Coast for the first time and I came up
with Gucci in pre-production and like
and like so I was on the first East
Coast for the first time I was a big fan
of Bose work so and this was like the
first movie I'd done in a while so there
were just a lot of levels of anxiety for
me so instead of acting like a normal
person an exiting conversation by saying
goodbye I would say Gucci and he started
doing it to embarrass me yeah I would
just say it all the time you know cuz
it's embarrassing when older people do
anything and then I would say good and
then I got so banal at some point it was
literally like grips being like is this
gay or not and then the videos were the
last we shot the videos the last two
days of the shoot and I always wanted of
a sign-off cuz all the kids and the
videos I saw ahead sign-offs
I was like oh my god of course so she
literally has the last word of the movie
which is alright well I'm the oldest
person up here and this film is
definitely Gucci yeah thank you very
much